i think actually so the problem
statement of choosing the most valuable
one i think is is too hard standard
so you just want to start a fire so if
it will burst into flames it's good now
did you hit the perfect place could i if
i put started the fire over here would
it have burned faster and bigger maybe
but i started the fire so and so that
means how do i recognize a segment
that's not very inflammable
so what does wet wood look like versus
dry wood
and i think a couple of things with the
target customer the key issues are going
to be
is this a target customer i understand
do i have access to them can i
communicate with them
clearly and do they have the kind of
funding or money necessary to
participate with my offer okay so if you
say okay
i got that okay then we go to the
compelling reason to buy so and the key
issue there is
how compelling is my compelling reason
to buy entrepreneurs have a compelling
reason to sell so we think all our
products should be bought and we think
the compelling reason to buy is i need
your money
but that's not how a customer thinks
right the customer is thinking no i'm
going to participate in your in your
offer because of something i need not
something you need and so and then the
issue is if and before if you're just
doing it for free and a lot of this
stuff initially starts for free then you
can you can kind of be a lot looser
because i'm i'm giving you enough a few
clicks of my life most people are
willing to donate a few clicks of their
life
the third one then is going to be
does my offer generally scratch the itch
that i said it would and so it's they
call it product market fit does my
product really really do this i mean i
know i wanted to say it does i want him
to buy it i've sort of said all the
right words but is that really me is
that really who we are and and there you
have to be brutally honest with yourself
a lot of times you hope it will and the
fee the markets giving you a message
saying no no and you're going yes yes no
so yeah it's a and being an entrepreneur
is a very funny state because
you need to have enough confidence to
hear a bunch of no's and keep going but
you can't be tone deaf right
you have to learn and not just be
stubborn and so that that that's that's
a a bit of a touch and then the final
one is you know is my offer in this
context truly differentiated enough
because when you're starting out nobody
knows who you are so it's not like
they're loyal to you so you really do
have to stand out at the beginning or
else the world would go well
why wouldn't i just go with one of the
other guys